I want to take one more step before I
let you guys loose on actually using
this right this number is special this
number is special but what about all
those numbers that aren't special like 2
& 3 we tried those out right what is the
derivative of something like say 2 to
the X we know because we graphed it we
know it's not to the X right that would
have been nice but do remember was just
a bit below okay and in the same way the
derivative of 3 to the X was more just 3
to the X right so so what is it what is
it it's yeah I can't add any more
changes to that okay what is it well
underneath this can you make a little
subheading underneath exponential the
little subheading is very originally
different bases say that again it's just
practice let's just practice it's a help
to grab oh man that's what's good all
right so what we want to do is we want
to take something which has a different
base we know what happens with either Y
X it's so lovely it's really boring it's
nice for a change that's something
boring you differentiate it nothing
happens but I want to consider what
happens when you have are the bases like
2 or 3 or 8 or whatever okay so I'm
gonna consider this guy a to the X where
a is any number not just not just a
which we know is a special guy
okay now this takes a bit of thought but
it's all of the groundwork we've laid
with Exponential's and logs which is
going to help us here okay this is an
exponential equation an equation with an
exponential in it right you can take any
exponential equation and rewrite it as a
log equation with logarithms in it right
all the same numbers but there's gonna
be a log involved how would I take this
guy and write up with laws where reckon
base
I just pause before you go astray this
is tricky right one of ways I remember
what happens next is the base of this is
the same as the base of that that that
doesn't change okay so then what's the
next thing that happens why
yeah and then you've only got one number
left right it's X very good okay very
good so what I've done is I've changed
the subject it was Y before now X is a
subject now do you remember what we've
got a few years when the base is e
that's really nice
right when the base is eat everything is
easy if only I could write this
logarithmic equation without some weird
we don't base if only I could change the
base oh wait we have a rule for this
right we can take this guy we have a
whole thing for changing the base of
this log how do I do it did I remember
how to change the base let me give you a
clue it's a fraction very good you've
got this number down the bottom so log
of this down the bottom and then log of
that on the top and then the base of the
new logs you can choose it to be
anything you like right you choose to be
two or ten or whatever what base do you
think we should sorry what base do you
think we should choose a base that might
be convenient to us right we're going to
choose the base err okay so we're gonna
write this log base e on the top log
base E on the bottom and in these two
numbers the top one goes to the top and
the bottom one goes to the bottom so
this is our change of base law okay
so I've just changed the basis of all of
this now I'm talking at ease this is
this is a language I like talking it
okay now it just needs to be a little
bit of twisting to get to what I want we
change the subject from Y to X it's a
bit weird though having the subject as X
I actually want it back to look like
this right so help me out can you help
me change the subject of this equation
back in to Y don't move this will be
really quick first thing we do is only
this guy right that's a bit gross so I'm
gonna write that multiplied on the other
side like so so far so good
okay I'm gonna be even lazier I'm just
going to continue over here and I'm
gonna write it not as the log base a is
a lazier way to write it there's an end
we'll talk about that a little bit later
looks like this okay with that now see
this it's a log equation remember how we
said every exponential equation you can
rewrite as a log equation
you know what every single log equation
you can rewrite as an exponential and
we'll get Y to be the subject again Y is
going to be equal to
hmm what's the base here we're over
there it's a right remember how this
base turned into this base so that base
is turned into this base what's the
power up here it's gonna be whatever is
over here right X log a you can
differentiate this you just did it twice
three times right I can find the
derivative of this what's the derivative
of the inside function right there it's
just the number right like 2 or 8 or
something like that so if a is just a
number there log of a number is another
number right so that's like two or three
away so what's the derivative of this
thing yeah it's well when though is 5x
right you told me the derivative was
five if this was 8x you tell me the
derivative is eight right so if this is
log a times X then the derivative will
be just log a right log a that's the
inside what's the outside it's e to the
power of a thing what happens when you
differentiate e to the power of the
thing you get e to the power of a thing
right it's I know right you like it it's
it's very specific now we're gonna leave
it for another day why that ends up
being your answer down to the bottom